so I was just on my way into work I'd
got off the bus and was heading over to
the Market Square when I crossed the
road at Theater Royal and heard a
collision like a car hitting a Bollard
so I turned around
and then someone screamed and then there
were two people on the floor
um I think and the the van was was still
there and then moments later the van
took off and then the police arrived
um during that I just ran over to see
how the two people were that were on the
road just to make just to see what I
could do to help
horrific for you to have to witness this
on the way to work
um this was quite early in the morning
what time was it were there other people
around was it quite busy yeah it's 5 30
in the morning there's a lot of people
going to
um cleaning jobs and Boots
um so there's lots of people around at
that time of morning
and how quickly did the police arrive on
the scene
there was a police van Within
a minute it was very quick and then more
people more police arrived or within
probably 20 minutes
um ambulance arrived in about 20 minutes
as well it was all very quick
and what did you see of those people on
the floor were they able to talk at that
point just clearly Taylor through yeah
yeah there was a male and a female the
female
um she could speak um she was in in pain
um from the impact of um hitting the
ground
um minted header head as well
um but she was still able to speak and
then a gentleman as well
um and he I think took the full brunt of
the van and he
um had head injuries
um
but was still awake he didn't lose
Consciousness or anything like that he
was still awake at that stage
and Francis did you see anything of the
driver
no the van had already gone by that
stage by the time I got to the people
um and once the police arrived what did
they say to you
um the police completely speaks to me
because I was looking after the woman in
particular
um the police were more focused on
getting the road closed off around us
and looking after the gentleman because
he was the one that had the obvious head
injuries and needed dealing with
straight away
and Francis there's been a string of
public figures you know including the
Prime Minister who have expressed their
shock
um over these attacks in these incidents
how does it leave you feeling you know
you're off to work this is the last
thing you expect to happen how did you
feel
I think at the time
um I didn't realize what was happening I
thought it was just a hit and run
um so you deal with that then I went to
work and then I started hearing more
along uh more on the Press
um to hear that three people would
potentially being killed
um and that there's been a third person
injured as well so it's quite
um shocking news you're on your way into
work the last thing anybody wants to be
seeing or dealing with